now first of all just get me if you can
provide us with uh what labor would try
and do to try and get these um two men
back uh do you think it's time now for
the russian ambassador to be called in
well this is a
really concerning situation
certainly for the families of nasa and
for sean pennade and athens from not too
far down the road from here in
nottinghamshire um you know these are uh
legitimate competencies are prisoners of
war such have significant rights they
should not have been tried by the
tribunal that they have been in the way
that they have been um and you know as a
result those rights aren't being upheld
i think it's really important that we
send a strong message back from this
country uh of our unity on this that
these gentlemen must have their rights
and they must be treated properly as as
they should be under the geneva consent
convention as robin walker said so you
know diplomatic efforts now must start
we heard from ali your correspondence
that that now that there's a little bit
of time for that to take place that now
must happen whether that's you know
calling the ambassador or whatever the
channels are open we must use all of
them and show a united front who expect
their rights to be upheld
okay thank you for that alex uh let's
just bring you back to some domestic
issues then if we can and the cost of
living crisis i mean
we've seen the petrol prices increasing
every single day at the pump what would
a labour government do to try and make
sure that people can afford to fill
their tanks
well again from talking to constituents
there are so much anxiety about their
ability to even get to work because of
the cost now of travel to do so you know
we think it was significant the action
we secured on the the windfall tax the
week before last and that will start to
filter through and help people but what
we call fall that and what we're calling
for now is an emergency budget that
helps tackle um the things that are
pushing up prices that are putting so
many pressures on people and that could
that could involve
a cancelling the national insurance rise
cutting
business rates for small businesses you
know finding ways to get pockets to get
money into people's pockets and and to
tackle inflation we need that now what
we've got at the moment is just this
kind of slow drift from the government
and hope that things will get better
so i think i picked up there you said
you might cancel the national insurance
right is that the only idea that the
labour party have
no that was that that's one that would
have the most direct most significant
impact and would be part of an emergency
budget but i also talked about cutting
business rates for small businesses as
well that would help the high streets
going to and help with jobs as well you
know we need a full emergency budget
because this is an emergency situation
this is pressures on on living that
frankly have not been seen in my
lifetime and what we've got at the
moment isn't enough so what you know
we're calling for that emergency budget
so we can take significant action and to
make life easier for people because
they're really struggling at the moment
uh mr norris did you know budget will be
coming in a few months time i mean the
argument would be that if you do an
emergency budget now and you make uh
changes to how the country's finances
look you'll have to do it again in the
autumn because these issues that we're
facing are not going away
yeah well i think this is going to need
you know sustained action i mean the the
the answer's kind of in the question
there we just got to ask people ask our
neighbours you know ask my constituents
can you wait a few more months for
action the message i'm getting back very
clearly is that they cannot wait so
that's why i think we have to act now
rather than kind of hoping we can drift
to to the autumn because i think that
would be really hard for lots and lots
of people if we did that
what about a cut in uh green taxes
is that something labeled support
which which ones you're referring to
there oh does tax is designed to make
sure that we get to our net zero
commitments
i mean i think that you know trying to
address our challenges there are many
ways i've mentioned a couple that we
could use i don't think compromising on
our net zero goals would be the way to
do that because actually what we know
from failing to tackle climate change is
that only puts up bills uh in the end as
well as obviously threatening the planet
in its existence at all so i wouldn't
support that i don't think that's the
right thing to do there are other things
we could do more quickly so that's why
we should be getting to parliament
having an emergency budget doing that
let's move you on then if we can alex
said to some things that are facing all
of us uh who use public transport this
summer that is the looming train strike
is labour in support of industrial
action for these railway workers who are
going to walk out for three days
well i you know as a traveler and with
constituents who are traveling too of
course we would rather see that there
aren't strikes you know but when there
are issues for people about their pay
and you know their ability to sustain
their family's finances at a time like
this when there are issues too about
safety they those you know are important
part of these negotiations as well then
you know people have the right to
withdraw their labor i hope we can avoid
that i think we can avoid that too you
know the government needs to get a grip
of this they've let this drift uh you
know negotiations are scheduled i
believe over the next few days let's get
round the table cool heads you know i
don't think i don't think that
the workers won't strike either let's
get this negotiated let's get a fair
deal and let's get you know keep trains
and public transport moving
oh what do you think a fair deal would
look like them for these royal workers i
mean they're saying that their uh paying
conditions haven't improved for many
many years do you think they should be
paid more
well of course i mean this is you know
this is the chickens coming home to
roost as well for for 10 years of bad
government policy on pay that's held
back you know people's living conditions
and now the bills have spiked as they
are it's made life incredibly difficult
um you know let's not forget let's not
lose sight these are key workers these
are the people you know we were clapping
for because they're keeping the country
going at their own personal risk uh when
we needed them to so of course i think
it's entirely reasonable that they're
asking uh for proper pace so they can
feed their families of course that's the
right thing and as you know key workers
will be affected by this strike because
they won't be able to get to work on the
trains
yeah which is why as i say you know we
we hope that that's avoidable that you
know i don't think it's i used to be a
union organizer myself i know that this
is always your your kind of action of
last resort i know that staff don't
enjoy doing it because they love to
providing the service they provide and
make you know helping people get on with
their lives and working with their with
their customers so of course it's the
last thing we want to see
but you know they need to be treated
properly at work they need to be able to
feed their families and they need to be
safe at work those are very very
reasonable demands that all of us would
ask for so now is the time for cool
heads let's get this negotiated let's
get a fair deal and let's keep keep the
public transport moving
okay alex norris says shadow levelling
up minister thank you very much for your
time this morning